hey there chet's mocha this is alex
kamal presently of the razorback
naomi if you're there i'd appreciate you
giving me a sign
i'd sort of like to make sure it's you
before we come over your ship's been
acting a mite odd and we're a little on
the jumpy side
don't she said knowing he couldn't hear
stay away
stay away everything hurt everything
whirled nothing was
easy when she got to her feet her head
swam she was afraid she was going to
pass out but if she bent over
she wasn't sure she'd have enough
strength to stand back up
she had to find a way to wave him off
she had to keep him from getting close
enough to be caught in the blast
whether it saved her life or not didn't
matter she'd had her good day
it was more than she'd expected and she
was so deeply weary
hey guys pete here time to discuss what
might happen in the season five finale
of the expanse
there's a lot going on with the
individual members of the rossi crew
and two-thirds of them are heading in
the same direction
or going to the same place this video
will pick up where my episode 9
breakdown left off
and we'll discuss where all the
characters are at in their stories
and speculate about what might happen in
episode 10.
no spoilers about what's to come but
there is still a spoiler warning if you
aren't caught up with the expanse
through season 5 episode 9 then this
video won't be for you
as someone who's read them i will be
referring to the books but won't mention
any future spoilers from them with that
out of the way
let's get going as a book reader the
finale is a different beast when it
comes to talking about what might happen
i know what happens at the end of book
five that has ramifications for
everything that comes after that and so
there's some stuff that i can't even
speculate like with air quotes about for
example
amos clarissa and eric made it off
planet earth and i don't think there's
going to be many changes in what happens
when they get to luna for that i'll just
throw out this reminder about their
situation
clarissa is by any definition an escaped
convict she was serving a life sentence
for
multiple homicides she wouldn't be able
to travel anywhere and beyond that she
tried to kill the captain of amos's ship
eric does bring some unique skills to
the table as a hacker and someone who
can fake ids
remember he's the one who gave timmy the
amos burton identity that got him off
earth in the first place
but even if he could do that for peaches
there's still this issue
with holden in universe so far nothing's
happened to make holden change his mind
about her
amos trip to earth reaffirmed his
commitment to the rossi and its crew
so those are the facts as we've seen
them and it's probably best that i just
leave that there
on the other hand one area where things
are sort of wide open is with the
rocinante this is a big question mark
since drummer
and her faction has been added to the
equation right now the rossi is burning
towards naomi
and they're going there after the zamaya
blew itself
up which also didn't happen in the books
i know the point of holden's ark in the
fifth book and how that plays out but in
the show's version of events there's a
lot of unrelated stuff floating around
him bull and monica
are both added to the rossi if you've
been following my videos you know i
think that monica probably is going to
play a role
in figuring out that the protomolecule
sample got away
didn't really see anything to change
that in the last episode
i mentioned that i thought bull was kind
of suspicious and he seemed almost
hostile
every time that naomi came up and there
might be something there but when i went
back and watched the scenes as i was
writing this script
i realized that he's also playing the
role of
the cautious one to keep holden in check
they went through a lot of pdc
rounds destroying all the torpedoes that
the zamaya had fired and that was one of
bull's sort of throwaway lines that we
don't have enough bullets to fight all
of the belter ships that are out there
so there might be something suspicious
going on with bull but he might just be
the grumpy voice of reason as well
marco ordering drummer to go after the
rasa nante
is a really big change in episode 9 he
told her to go meet up with the cereal
mall and the koto
and those are martian ships that's been
confirmed in the show when they sent
that message to karol a couple episodes
back
the rasanante is one badass gunship
that's low on bullets
with the koto and the cereal maul the
other side basically has two of their
own rossies
and then they'll have drummers three
ships on top of that
the odds don't look good and really the
rossi coming out ahead in a fair
fight with replacement crew five-on-one
it wouldn't make for the most believable
outcome there's really been no
introduction of a resistance to the free
navy among the belters
and alva serala mentioned that the un
had pulled their fleets back to protect
the inner planets
i guess there's an outside chance that
she could help out but really it feels
like it's all pointing towards drummer
she's in a crazy situation she's
dedicated herself to this new family and
that's gotten her in bed with the free
navy
her new boss marco is directly
responsible for the deaths of people who
are important to her the deaths of
ashford fred johnson
and now she knows that he strapped naomi
a woman that she loves to a bomb
it's really hard to see how she doesn't
break away but at the same time there's
immediate consequences
considering that carol knows this and
takes every opportunity to push drummer
knowing that she doesn't want anything
to happen to surge
is really something that's going to have
to be addressed if they rendezvous with
the koto in the cereal mall
i think a victory against the ross ante
would be guaranteed
so she either has to come up with a plan
somehow create a diversion where she can
escape in one of the ships
which think about it that wouldn't be
easy to do there's no reason why they
wouldn't just hunt her down
and destroy the ship i'm really
interested to see what she does
i have no idea really she is loosely
based on a character that has an
important role in the sixth book but
this is all pretty much
uncharted territory so we're gonna have
to wait and see
for naomi's story some of the details
are different with the chetsmoka
but it's mostly the same her escape and
what she's done on the chatsmoka so far
is where they've stuck closest to the
book as far as the major storylines go
except maybe with amos and clarissa we
know from the end of the last episode
that alex and bobby are closing in on
her location and she's gonna have to try
to figure out a way
to warn them about the proximity trigger
that's attached to her ship
this is another area where i shouldn't
speculate too much since i probably know
what's going to happen but there is one
added dimension of excitement here
and that's alex's future as you know the
actor who plays alex is not gonna be
returning to season
six and i've stayed away from
speculating about what they were gonna
do with that because
those allegations that got him fired
didn't come out until after they had
finished filming season five
for that reason they didn't write this
season they didn't start out with a plan
to write him out of the script
that said there are a lot of rumors out
there that the show will
actually send him off they added
something or
at least they'll address it in some way
not leave it hanging
i can't confirm any of those things but
they could mess around
and kill him off it is possible i mean
it's a bad situation all the way around
alex is an important character
throughout the rest of the series
there's no doubt about that
at the same time recasting him always
seemed kind of weird though when they're
only guaranteed to do one more season
he's important as i said but it's kind
of how he works with the other
characters though
in my mind he pairs up with the others
more than he has these big major
development arcs in his story and so out
of the main crew he is the easiest one
to imagine them writing out
the actor not coming back does present
an opportunity to have a shocking event
that nobody saw coming in the finale
though
not sure how they would do that or how
they would go about it but the thought
keeps creeping into the back of my mind
that's not to say there aren't easier
ways to take him out of the story
and i could also see them doing
something like having him decide to go
back to mars
to go be with his son or something along
those lines
just walk away from it all in light of
all the changes that the free navy
and the rocks falling are bringing to
the solar system it doesn't really jive
with his story of being a guy who needs
to be out there flying on these long
trips and that being the reason he left
his wife in the first place
but that might be the best that they can
do with a bad set of circumstances
it'll be interesting to see where they
go with it
the changes in soul system are something
i expect to learn more about to set the
stage for the final season the mars
parliament building being attacked
hasn't been mentioned since episode four
soviet air and the bar keith are still
out there somewhere we haven't heard of
them really much at all
and we know things are pretty chaotic in
some of the major cities on earth
i have ideas about what's going on with
these things from reading the books i'm
hoping to learn more about all of them
in the finale and i'm interested to hear
what your theories are in the comments
especially if you haven't read the book
with avasarala sliding into the
secretary general role
in the last episode i'm guessing we'll
get some things from her
it's interesting when you think about
what they did with her this season
she was sort of locked out when nancy
gal took over
she figured out what was going on with
the rocks and no one would listen to her
then they brought her back in and still
no one wanted to listen to her because
she was advocating for a non-violent
response
now she's back in the driver's seat and
the situation could potentially be
getting much
worse they did attack palace station and
her thoughts about that
probably were right that probably would
radicalize a lot of belters
so we'll see what they do with her
what's going on hopefully we'll find out
more about the
overall situation on earth as far as the
after effects of the rocks hitting and
how hard that might make her job in the
future
the last thing that i need to mention is
marco and the free navy
they've sort of been going around doing
something but we never really see what
it is we don't know what their plan is
we've seen him staring at monitors quite
often we've seen him monitoring the
activity of the un
and martian fleets we've seen him
looking at the ring gates
in episode nine there was another moment
where he was looking at something going
towards the ring
and someone pointed this out in the
comments that in the opening of each
episode
they show his fleet and it's moved to a
different place at the beginning of each
episode
they were by jupiter then saturn and in
the opening of episode nine
they were doing a flyby of uranus that
is the planet that is
nearest the ring gate so that is
interesting that we see them moving in
that direction
at least in the opening sequences beyond
that it's a mystery
and man i can't wait to find out i'm
really excited for this final episode
it's been a lot of fun covering this
season and i wanted to thank everyone
for watching
i've got a handful of other expanse
videos that'll be coming out over the
next couple of weeks of course i'll be
doing a breakdown of the finale and an
ending explained
but i have some other topics i want to
tackle as well
to set up things for the long wait until
season six
i'm gonna leave it there let me know
what you're thinking about in the
comments
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
thanks for watching guys i'll talk to
you soon